la mañana de este jueves 24 de diciembre
la enfermera maría irene ramírez jefa
del servicio en la unidad de cuidados
intensivos del hospital rubén leñero de
la ciudad de mexico se convirtió en la
primera mujer del país en recibir la
vacuna de facer fue en una ceremonia
encabezada por el subsecretario de salud
federal hugo lópez gatell y la jefa de
gobierno de la ciudad de mexico claudia
sheinbaum llevada a cabo en el hospital
general de la capital del país se hizo
un enlace en vivo para que el presidente
andrés manuel lópez obrador pudiera
atestiguar desde palacio nacional el
arranque de esta primera etapa de la
campaña de vacunación al personal médico
que está en la línea de batalla contra
el covent 19 de manera paralela en el
hospital regional número 2 del instituto
mexicano del seguro social en el estado
de querétaro la enfermera maría del
socorro lora fue quien recibió este
antídoto de facer y asimismo en el
estado de mexico en el hospital militar
de toluca el médico cirujano daniel díaz
fue el primero en ser inoculado al
concluir estas primeras dosis esta
aplicación
primeras dosis los médicos y las
enfermeras coincidieron en señalar que
no hay que bajar la guardia pues el
hecho de que ya esté en el país la
vacuna no quiere decir que no estemos
aún en una situación crítica y es
indispensable el uso de cubrebocas y la
sana distancia